نحن الان في ولايه غازي عنتاب في حي ال
ابراهيملي حيث ما زالت عمليات رفع الانقاض
مستمره وصلنا الى هذا البناء هنا المعدات
الثقيله تعمل على ازاله
الانقاض من محيط هذا المبنى كما نشاهد في
حين ما زالت الفرق تعمل بشكل دقيق وحساس
في مواقع اخرى من هذا البناء في بمعدات
بسيطه ودقيقه وهذا يشير الى انه قد يكون
هناك ناجين تحت الانقاض يتم العمل على
اخراجهم ما تم ابلاغنا به والمؤسف بان هذه
هذا البناء كان يتواجد فيه كامل سكانه وهو
مؤلف من عشره طوابق وهذا الامر قد يشير
الى انه من اكثر المباني الذي يكون فيه
خسائر بشريه من بين المباني الذي الذي
رافقنا رفع الانقاض فيها وهنا الفرق
منتشره بالاضافه الى الاهالي الذين قد
يكونوا من ذوي العوائل وبانتظار سماع
اخبار عن
اخراج وانقاذ بعضهم وكما نشاهد هذه الخيام
التي تم تجهيزها هنا في هذا الموقع
والتجهيزات هنا على اشدها المعدات الفرق
وايضا حتى الغذاء متوفر لهم في هذه الخيمه
وايضا اود التنويه الى نقطه اخرى هناك
بناء لم يتم رفع الانقاب فيه وذلك يعود
الى ان هذا البناء كان خاليا عندما سقط
وهذا البناء سقط جراء الهزات الارتداديه
وكان الاهالي قد غادروه ولم يتم فيه اي من
اعمال رفع
الانقاض او اي اعمال اخرى جرت في هذا هذا
المبنى وهذا يشير بان من الاب التي سقطت
فيها الاجزاء الاولى كانت بها الخسائر
البشريه الكبرى بينما التي سقطت في فيما
بعد جراء الهزات الارتداديه كانت الخسائر
البشريه فيها اقل عمر الحوراني الجزيره من
ولايه غازي عنتاب جنوبيه تركيا